when your users start demanding more
from your applications a robust cicd
pipeline is going to help you maintain
your quality so how do I set up
continuous delivery or deployment for my
cloud run project so the first thing you
want to do is to make sure you're using
a separate Google Cloud project for your
test environment and for your production
environment and if you want continuous
delivery you can add a deployment step
in your Cloud build configuration file
so that your built software gets
deployed to your test environment and if
I want continuous deployment I make that
last step deployed to production instead
you can set up a build trigger to only
kick off your Cloud build config when
code is committed to a particular branch
in Source control your main branch might
represent production and you can merge
code into that Branch for deployments to
production very good can't wait to start
using this for my applications uh you
know yeah so far I've been deploying my
apps uh by entering g-cloud run deploy
manually from the band line and there's
nothing wrong with that but